K is
racist uh app plotting racism I see
people places things in words now
there's even racist Birds it's true as
wokeness never truly ends they change
the names of Our Feathered Friends the
American
ortholog society plans to remove all
bird names derived from a person in an
attempt to make bird watching more
inclusive there's the word inclusive cuz
that's what keeps black brown and trans
people from looking at creatures with
beaks it's their names and not that bird
watching is about as exciting as waxing
Joy Bear's chin
hair sorry but according to these wokers
dozens of famous birds have names
clouded by racism misogyny and genocide
for example the ottobon sheerwater will
no longer be linked to otton society
founder James oton because the Dude
owned slaves well with that standard how
about all the black folks whose last
names are Washington Monroe or even
Jefferson should they change their names
thank God Sherman Hemley isn't alive to
see
this I miss Wheezy
too Wheezy you got right thank you the
name changes will initially focus on 80
species so having got bored with schools
and streets and monuments now it's Birds
but is there any Merit to this new
renaming and what about the Birds
themselves turns out they could be
racist and not just Jim
Crow here we go take a
listen I'll say I'll say if we still had
slaves I wouldn't have to build my own
damn snowman what a shame say there F
seeing as how we're both white and all
what do you think about joining me for a
good oldfashioned cross
burning gee Mr Leghorn how do I talk
just just like you well that's easy
little one just use your favorite racial
slur like
this
the
oh
terrible that real Tyrus as an animal
lover will this solve the bigotry that
is so rampant in the bird watching
Community I really hope so about damn
time you know need to change the name
from black birds
obviously dark
Birds this is so stupid like I'm sorry
like the first bird on the thing should
have been like the Woodcock let's get
rid of that one okay that one's a little
it's a little offensive when you're like
hey kids come to the forest we can look
at Woodcock you don't want that change
that name these people are so stupid MH
the autobond society was changing the
name of the sheer waterer bird because
it's named after sheerwater Autobon but
they don't change their name yeah
yes to a bird that if you saw it you
would be like oh sparrow and go about
your day like this is the most random
stupid virtue signaling thing yes cuz so
many birds are going to send them thank
you notes like this my whole life
oppressed being named after somebody
successful this just happened in the
wrong time period is the dumbest thing
ever yeah like yeah change the names but
first on the list if you're going to
change any name get that Woodcock out of
there that's it's a lot cat are we
running out of racist things I mean now
we're just basically at the bottom of a
bird cage I just feel like bird watching
is probably like the most inclusive
thing out there already yeah nobody has
ever been like sorry you're not cool
enough you can't come watch
birds like there's no bouncer no there
isn't there isn't and also I went to
Africa yes that's it
no uh and the Safari guide on my Safari
that I went to in
Africa um he said that he thinks that
people keep changing the name birds so
that people need to keep buying the
books oh see you go to Africa you learn
stuff yeah you're going to tell us you
went to Africa afca every day as I was
there I was like I can feel this
becoming my entire personality and I'm
not going to stop it's like when um uh
uh what's it Michael Scott went to
Jamaica and he bought sandals in Jamaica
yeah yeah and he bought came back with a
big uh brass drum remember yep I also
saw that one pictures of his boss with
no top on that was that was good no cat
is the college student that like we'll
spend the semester abroad and come back
like with a French accent like sorry I I
was just in Paris for yeah except for me
it only took a
week Tom this must as a racist you must
be very UPS
set you actually do Bird Watch don't you
I do like bird watching of course I've
done it I watch them I watch them and
then I shoot
them that's good you shoot them out of
the
sky that's actually a bigger problem
look what about the windmills the white
windmills which kill millions of birds a
year better not be black birds no black
cats kill birds he just outed himself
you made a joke though that the birds
were racist but
Blue Jays are racist really against
white people they're always attacking me
the Blue Jays they attack me and they
attack my dog and my dog is you know I
know the dog is in a race but my dog's
white and uh no I mean
like those blue jays come at you though
they do but and you know Tyrus they are
changing the Autobon Society they
haven't done it yet because they still
have all the calendars and everything
once they get rid of all the calendars
in the stationary they're changing their
name so they never will anyone here own
an
autobond calendar you two may
leave Emily uh do you think there's any
any kind of sensible reason for this or
is it just no no I'm actually very
relieved that America's priorities are
in line like World War III is nearing
we're declining as a society elections
are coming up but I'm glad that we're
changing the names of birds can you name
me like three birds even just three
species of birds
actually go for it I want you to go for
it something yeah I can
hummingbird Mocking Bird course parrot
yes okay well honestly no it's crazy
parrots they just wake up every day and
they're green you didn't even say
penguin and you love p is that a bird
that's not considered a bird turkey
turkey those two people that left you
can come back
to is a bird is a penguin a bird all
right enough with the birds coming up an
adorable pallet cleanse from Greg's
animal friends hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else